yo creo que es sin duda una de las
grandes ganadoras pues no solo por la
elección sino porque es un liderazgo
nuevo que ya puso a prueba su poder
electoral es francia márquez sin duda
creo que es un contrapeso a muchas de
las ideas y sobre todo el círculo
cercano de petro que se ha vuelto un
poco muy institucionalista que venían de
otros gobiernos como el gobierno santos
yo creo que francia trae la fuerza de la
del trabajo de base que hoy está
reflejado en el pacto histórico y que
seguramente va a impulsar agendas muy
importantes alrededor del tema ambiental
alrededor del tema de los feminismos
alrededor del tema de los territorios en
conflicto particularmente ella viene del
departamento más conflictivo de colombia
que es el cauca que tiene los índices
más graves de asesinato de líderes
sociales de hecho hoy en guapi cauca
mataron al menos dos personas que
estaban en militando en el pacto
histórico una de ellas testigo electoral
y creo que francia viene con esa fuerza
obviamente hay que recordar que la
vicepresidencia es un cargo que no tiene
funciones definidas y que más bien
existe en caso de que el presidente le
pase algo pero hemos tenido
vicepresidentes profundamente
protagónicos como germán vargas lleras
que de hecho pues hizo su campaña
presidencial en parte en la digamos en
la vicepresidencia y con la cartera de
vivienda debajo creo que la
vicepresidencia de marta lucía ramírez
pasó mucho más por debajo del radar
incluso siendo canciller no logró
destacarse pero este va a ser pues
primero es un hito para colombia que una
mujer afro llegue a esta posición
demuestra que puede haber una
multiculturalidad en las élites
políticas del país en quienes nos
gobiernan y además creo que francia
tiene unas agendas propias que van a
poner muchas veces en tensión a gustavo
porque pues gustavo va a entrar a ver
que gobernar no es lo mismo que hacer
oposición y creo que es un ejercicio que
las fuerzas opositoras siempre prueban
cuando estaban en gobierno y ahí
seguramente va a haber unas tensiones
interesantes que pueden ser muy
enriquecedoras para el proyecto del
pacto histórico